some paris airport workers voted to end
their protest after talks with
management showed signs of progress
staff have staged a number of walkouts
in the past month to demand better pay
and conditions they say they are
overworked and underpaid
inflation is soaring but our salaries
have not increased so what we have been
asking for is an extra 300 a month for
every airport worker
with a number of flights cancelled or
delayed in recent weeks some travellers
are taking precautions
we've come early in case we're stuck
here you have to plan for these things
in advance
we were aware of the strike so we
arrived earlier because we were worried
the post-pandemic mix of staff shortages
and inflation have led to similar
strikes in some other european countries
in spain cabin crew for some low-cost
airlines are planning walkouts over pay
this month while scandinavian airlines
has drastically cut its services because
of an ongoing pilot strike meanwhile
british airways has cancelled ten
thousand summer flights because of a
lack of workers
with borders reopening and covered
restrictions lifting demand for travel
is surging here in paris international
travelers are back in big numbers for
the first time in nearly two years
even if the airport workers demands are
met this expert says that staff
shortages are likely to remain a problem
for some time
airports here lost more than 10 000
workers from ground staff to pilots
during the pandemic on flights were cut
so there are huge shortages the problem
is that you can't hire these workers
from one day to another many need
training and they certainly won't be
operational in time for the summer
after being grounded for so long many
people are enjoying being able to jet
off again for work or pleasure but the
ongoing strikes and planned protests
suggest it could be a turbulent summer
for travellers
natasha butler al jazeera paris